well I think first of all we've got to
complete this project on the 300 million
today we've opened this plant the first
new plant in the UK for over a decade
and also the first plant ever to be
focused purely on electric vehicles but
you'll hear a lot of terminology used
you know commercial electric vehicles we
can no longer survive by being a one
product one market company we have to
spread our wings both in terms of export
but also in terms of our product so yes
you will see more but maybe not
immediately so does this mean the London
black cab is going to be sold far more
internationally than it has been to date
absolutely I mean if we look at around
about 2020 we'll be looking at about 50%
of our manufacturing being exported we
start sales into London in the last
quarter of this year and I will be
followed in the first quarter of 2018
initially into Europe in terms of the
Netherlands Germany Spain France and
Norway and followed up with other
markets the new vehicle you can see is
still very much the iconic black cab and
I think it's true it's a taxi for every
city because not only does it offer that
perfect transport solution it is now
going to contribute to lowering
emissions levels in every city and every
city has this problem and we have a
growing tendon in urbanization that's
going to continue in the world that can
only happen if we clean up our cities
there and how economical taxi drivers
going to find this new vehicle compared
with existing models that's a perfect
way of answering the question general
most people ask me what is the price of
the vehicle but you truly understand
this you understand the fact that it's a
total cost of ownership the combination
of the original purchase price with the
running costs the pout the fuel it you
have to put in which will be able to put
ominously electric and the lower
maintenance costs mean that when you add
everything together this is a very good
business case for the taxi driver and
the total cost of only
ship will be lower than the current
vehicle cause London's black taxi
drivers are under siege at the moment
from the likes of uber EU confident that
they're still going to be a sufficiently
strong market for this product I believe
there definitely will look in terms of
private hire cars there's always been a
place for private hire they will always
remain a place just as there will always
remain a place for a premium purpose to
built taxi that is both accessible safe
and trustworthy what about the skills
base in Coventry obviously Pirjo
departed from the city a decade ago do
you have the skills based in the city to
to make this product I've been really
really excited by the talent that we've
been able to to bring into this company
we're currently at 600 people that's
three times where we were in 2015
ultimately this new product in this new
factory will create a thousand new jobs
here in the heart of British industry